hello i'm brian darby i'm professor of
material science at the university of
manchester my particular interests in
how 3d printing can be used in medicine
if you read the newspapers you might get
the impression that very soon we'll be
3d printing whole organs which can be
used for transplant surgery really i
think we are many years away from that
sort of application in medicine to print
a complete organ is a very very
complicated piece of engineering we need
to know exactly how an organ works and
even biologists don't know completely
how an organ works at every level of its
structure what we can do is we can
produce things that look like organs but
generally they don't work like organs
the best example for that would be in
repairing bones what we can do with 3d
printing is if there's a large piece
missing
we can print a replica of the piece
that's missing to fit exactly into the
body we can make it look like bone on an
internal structure sufficiently
accurately that the body will grow new
bone tissue into the printed structure
and over a period of time that print
instructor will vanish leaving a perfect
fit a really good repair